في الكويت فيديو لتكريم طالبات ارتدينا
الحجاب اثار حاله كبيره من الجوده المقطع
الفيديو مدته 30 ثانيه شاهده الملايين
ومباشره بعد انتشار هذا الفيديو اشتعلت
التعليقات بين مرحب
ومنتقل المعترضون مشاهدينا ومنهم جمعيات
مدنيه اعتبروا ان تكريم الطالبات بسبب
حجابهم انما هو تمييز في الطفوله بل وصل
البعض بوصفه بغسيل المخ على الجانب الاخر
هناك من استنكر هذه الهجمه ضد المدرسه
ومديرتها وقالوا انها مربيه فاضله وتسعى
لغرس الاخلاق الحميده والايجابيه وانما
حدث ليس الا مجرد تكريم
[موسيقى]
يعني شو وجه الاعتراض على تكريم فتيات
بهذا الشكل البعض قال بانه يعني هو ليس
فقط تمييز ضد الطالبات غير المحجبات هو قد
يكون هل هذا حقيقي يعني يثير القلق بانه
قد يكون طريقه لوضع الضغط على الطالبات
غير المحجبات لكي يتحجبني يعني بالتاكيد
بالتاكيد هذا قد يكون احد احد
الحواجز والمخاوف اول شيء احنا في مدرسه
احنا المدرسه هذا مكان اكاديمي لا باس من
تكريم الفائقات في مجالات الدراسه
والمجالات الاكاديميه والمجالات الانشطه
اللي في المدرسه هذا طبعا لا باس منه بل
هو تعزيز لدورهم الاكاديمي والتفوق في هذه
المجالات لكن لما احنا نتكلم وتحديدا في
هذه المرحله ان التكريم على اساس ظاهري
على اساس شكلي قد يؤثر بشكل او باخر على
بقيه طالبات خصوصا
يعني الطالبات
كرموهم المدرسه حتى يشجعونهم على تمسك
بالحجاب وهل الاعتراض
اول شيء مثل ما قلت لكم العمر صغير هذا
واحد اثنين هذا قرار واذا كان
اتخاذ القرار التاثير على اتخاذ القرار
على طفله في هذا العمر انه والله شافت
كرمه ومتفوقات كرمهم محجبات فقد تتاثر
بهذا التكريم وتتحجب عن غير قناعه غير
قناعه
واذا ما تحجبت تحس انه اوكي انا انا
معزوله انا انا بعيده عن التكريم او عن
الشكل الصحيح هذا امر ما هو جيد في هذا
العمر تحديدا لان هذا قرار عمر
[موسيقى]